Good morning John.
I had the pleasure of attending YouTube's Education summit recently
and meeting a ton of amazing ed-YouTubers
including CGP Grey, who, everyone agrees the world needs more of.
He told me that making videos in his style was very hard
and so today, to prove it to him that I could do it, I'm going to tell you everything you ever wanted to know about apples.
No... not those apples
Original apples,  no the original apples
Apples are wonderful. Sweet, Tart, Big, Small, Red, Green, Yellow, Brown, Purple
Every apple that has ever passed your lips I can almost guarantee
was descended from wild apple trees in Kazakhstan.
American as apple pie... Nope! Immigrants.
The oldest known apple pie recipe was written in 1381.
Apples may have indeed have been the first cultivated fruit tree in human history
And the fruit has been part of Asian and European culture since
Well... hmm
Unfortunately until the 17th century the word for apple in both old english and latin was used as a generic term for all fruits
Apple, apple, apple, apple, apple
Not berries though - they had their own word but nuts? apples.
so its difficult to determine whether it's 'apple apples' being written about in ancient texts
or when it percimine apples or fig apples or pomegranate apples
Nonetheless their sweet decadence has them heavily featured in greek myths
Execially ones about beauty and sexuality
and throwing a apple at a young lady was a way of saying hey I fancy you
as long as you didn't throw it too hard.
while apples are immigrants, America does have some great apple history.
particularly the story of Johnny Appleseed who, unlike Paul Bunyan and Pecos Bill, was actually a real person
John Chapman was a businessman, nomad, missionary and kinda crazy person
who crossed the american frontier making sure everyone had plenty of apple saplings
many american settlers were actually required to plant fruit trees on their property
as a sign that they were improving the land that they had claimed as theirs
Chapmans business operation relied on him planting tree nurseries from seed and then selling the saplings
which, for anyone who knows anything about apple trees, sounds nuts
apple fruits exhibit something known as extreme heterozygosity
meaning that the apple of a daughter tree will look and taste nothing like that of the mother
the default phenotype for apple taste appears to be terrible
once you do find a tree with a tasty apple you craft buds or limbs off that tree creating clones
of the original tree on top of the root stalk of a seeded tree
Chapman didn't do that
he just planted the seeds creating tons of terrible tasting apples
why ... no one cared
no one was interested in eating them; apples were mashed for their juice and fermented into booze
first because everyone had seen dysentery first hand and no one trusted the water
and second because, well, booze
while most apples were destined for cider, farmers always had their eye out for that one tree with nice, tasty eating apples in the orchard
and those that found good ones won a kind of cosmic lottery and often became rich selling grafts and apples
for example the tree that scotsman John Mcintosh discovered on a farm in 1796 in Canada
a small sweat crisp apple, red with swatches of green
from that one tree in effect came every Mcintosh apple ever eaten
the Mcintosh apple was so successful that it inspired the naming of the Apple Macintosh
which some how happens to be the kind of computer I'm editing this video on right now
There you have it! Everything you ever wanted to know about apples
or... yeah.
DFTBA